HANNITY, WHILE PICKING UP WHERE
YOU LEFT OFF.
HAVE A GOOD NIGHT.
I AM LAURA INGRAHAM.
THIS IS THE INGRAHAM ANGLE FROM
WASHINGTON.
AN ALARMING EXCHANGE OF THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES REVEALS
THE TRUE INTENTION OF DEMOCRATS
WHEN IT COMES TO YOUR FIREARMS.
WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK AND SHOW
YOU THIS BACK AND FORTH AND
SPEAK TO THE REPUBLICAN WHO
ELICITED THIS ADMISSION.
BUT FIRST, THE REAL MILITARY
DESTROYERS.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
LET'S FACE IT.
THE LEFT IS REALLY GOOD AT
DESTROYING THINGS.
THEY DESTROYED EDUCATION DURING
THE PANDEMIC WITH ALL THOSE
SCHOOL CLOSURES.
THEY DESTROYED RESPECT FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WE SEE THAT ALL THE TIME.
THE DESTROYED HISTORICAL
MARKERS.
THEY DESTROYED ENTIRE CITY
BLOCKS TO HONOR GEORGE FLOYD.
THEY DESTROYED INDEPENDENT
MEDICAL PRACTICES OF WITH
OBAMACARE.
THEY DESTROYED FREE SPEECH ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES MAY HOPING TO
DESTROY THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE,
THE FILIBUSTER, THE U.S. SENATE,
AND IF WE LET THEM, THE
CONSTITUTION ITSELF.
BASICALLY ANYTHING THAT HOLDS
TRADITIONAL AMERICAN IDEALS HAS
TO BE DESTROYED.
NOW IT LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE ON THE
PATH TO DESTROY OUR ALL
VOLUNTEER MILITARY.
THE MEDIA OBSESS ON THE FAKE
CLIMATE CHANGE CRISIS, THEY ARE
GLOSSING OVER A REAL CRISIS.
THE GRADUAL DEPLETION OF OUR
MILITARY FIGHTING FORCE.
AS A RESULT, MOST AMERICANS
DON'T HAVE A CLUE ABOUT HOW DIRE
THE SITUATION IS.
HOW BAD IS IT?
THE ARMY IS RIGHT NOW SHORT OF
ITS 60,000 SOLDIER RECRUITING
GOAL FOR THE FISCAL YEAR BY
HALF.
THAT'S 30,000 SOLDIERS.
FOR NEXT YEAR, IT'S EXPECTED TO
BE EVEN WORSE.
DON'T FORGET THE ARMY HAD
ALREADY REDUCED ITS ANNUAL
RECRUITING TARGET BY 5,000
BECAUSE OF AN EARLIER SHORTFALL.
AND YES WE HAVE KNOWN FOR MONTHS
THE PROBLEM IS OCCURRING ACROSS
ALL MILITARY BRANCHES.
THIS IS A COMPLETE DISASTER.
THE WHITE HOUSE AND CONGRESS
SHOULD BE WORKING 24/7 TO
ADDRESS THIS.
INSTEAD THEY SPEND THEIR DAYS
TALKING ABOUT WIND POWER AND
GENERALLY SIX.
WHERE IS THE WAR HAWK LIZ CHENEY
ON ALL OF THIS?
LATE TODAY THE ARMY ISSUED A
FIVE-PAGE MEMO THAT TRIED TO
EXPLAIN WHY THIS IS HAPPENING.
CLAIMING THEY ARE IN A WAR FOR
TALENT ARE AND THE MOST
CHALLENGING RECRUITING
ENVIRONMENT SINCE 1973.
>> RECRUITING MOTIVATED, FIT,
ACADEMICALLY PROFICIENT MEN AND
WOMEN CONTINUES TO BE A
CHALLENGE.
ONLY 22% OF MILITARY AGE MEN AND
WOMEN IN THE UNITED STATES ARE
QUALIFIED TO SERVE.
>> Laura: READ BETWEEN THE
LINES.
HE SEEMS TO BE SAYING THAT OUR
POTENTIAL POOL OF RECRUITS IS
TOO FAT, TOO STUPID, TOO
UNMOTIVATED.
THAT'S NOT ALL.
SPEAK WE'VE GOT UNPRECEDENTED
CHALLENGES.
A POST COVID-19 ENVIRONMENT AND
LABOR MARKET BUT ALSO
COMPETITION, PRIVATE COMPETITION
WITH PRIVATE COMPANIES THAT TO
CHANGE THEIR INCENTIVES OVER
TIME.
>> Laura: THIS IS ABSURD.
DID WE NOT HAVE A FREE MARKET
FOR LABOR COMPETITION BEFORE THE
LAST FEW YEARS?
AS FOR THE POST COVID-19
ENVIRONMENT REFERENCE, THE
GENERALS SHOULD HAVE BEEN MORE
BLUNT.
THE VACCINE MANDATE IS
DEFINITELY A FACTOR HERE.
>> THIS MAY GET EVEN WORSE
BECAUSE THE NATIONAL GUARD AND
ARMY RESERVE ARE FACING THE
PROSPECT THAT SOME 60,000 OF
THEIR FORCE MAY NOT BE WILLING
TO GET THE COVID VACCINE AND IF
THEY DON'T GET THE COVID
VACCINE, THEY WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO BE PART OF THE ACTIVE FORCE.
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO BE
ACTIVATED AND GO.
>> Laura: AT LEAST AT LEAST
CNN DID THE REPORT.
I GIVE THEM KUDOS FOR THAT BUT
WHAT A NIGHTMARE.
THEY HAD TO KNOW THIS WOULD
HAPPEN, THE MILITARY DID AND
THEY DID IT ANYWAY.
OF COURSE DON'T PRESS
GENERAL MILLEY OR SECRETARY
AUSTIN ABOUT ALL OF THIS BECAUSE
THEY ARE MORE WORRIED ABOUT
PROPPING UP THE UKRAINIAN
MILITARY THAN FIXING HOURS.
>> WE ARE GOING TO KEEP MOVING
AT THE SPEED OF WAR.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
MIGHT DOES NOT MAKE RIGHT HERE
WE'RE GOING TO STAND STRONG WITH
OUR FELLOW CONTACT GROUP
MEMBERS, AND WE'RE GOING TO
SUPPORT UKRAINE'S SELF-DEFENSE
FOR THE LONG HAUL.
AND WERE GOING TO DEFEND THE
RULES-BASED INTERNATIONAL ORDER
THAT PROTECTS US ALL.
>> Laura: SO MUCH TO UNPACK
THERE BUT THE SPEED OF WAR?
THEY ARE THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
THOUGHT THE AFGHAN ARMY CAN HOLD
OUT FOR A YEAR BUT OF COURSE IT
COLLAPSED IN JUST A FEW WEEKS.
THEIR ADVICE AND ANALYSIS IS
CONSISTENTLY WRONG.
UNDER THEIR LEADERSHIP, THE
RUSSIANS DON'T FEAR US.
AND THE CHINESE DON'T FEAR US.
THEY ARE THREATENING US OVER
PELOSI'S POTENTIAL TRIP TO
TAIWAN.
MEANWHILE, YOUNG AMERICANS
AREN'T INSPIRED BY THEM.
I HATE TO BREAK INTO THE
GENERALS BUT OUR TROOPS DON'T
SIGN UP TO FIGHT FOR THEIR
IDIOTIC RULES-BASED
INTERNATIONAL ORDER.
WHICH ONLY BASICALLY HELPS
CHINA, BIG BUSINESS, AND THE
GLOBALISTS.
HAS THE INTERNATIONAL ORDER THAT
GENERAL AUSTIN WAS JUST
REFERENCING PROTECTING US FROM
FENTANYL OR BORDER CRIME OR THE
CLOSING OF OUR FACTORIES, THE
OUTSOURCING OF OUR JOBS?
HASN'T STOPPED CHINA FROM
BUILDING AS MANY COAL PLANTS AS
IT DAM WELL PLEASES.
OF COURSE NOT.
>> ARE SENIOR LEADERS' INABILITY
TO HAVE COURAGE, THEIR HYPOCRISY
AFFECTING ALL OF THINGS.
SENIOR MILITARY LEADERS HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT WE CAN'T TRUST
THEM AND YOU WOULD BE NAIVE TO
THINK THAT A YOUNG AMERICAN
ISN'T GETTING ONLINE, GOING ON
THE INTERNET, AND SING ALL THE
MISSTEPS THAT WE CAN CLEARLY SEE
IN OUR SENIOR MILITARY LEADERS.
>> Laura: THE FACTOR OF THE
MATTER IS, IN LARGE PART OUR
MILITARY IS SUFFERING A SEVERE
RECRUITMENT CRISIS BECAUSE OUR
MILITARY LEADERSHIP IS MORE
FOCUSED ON BEING WOKE AND
FOLLOWING DR. FAUCI THEN WINNING
WARS.
LIBERALS IN THE HOUSE ARE
TOTALLY FINE WITH IT, NOT
SURPRISING.
IN FACT THEY WANT TO MAKE THE
MILITARY EVEN MORE RADICAL.
>> WE CAN AND MUST DO BETTER TO
ENSURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THIS WORLD-CLASS
TRAINING TO OUR FEMALE MILITARY
LEADERS AROUND THE WORLD.
THIS AMENDMENT WOULD SIMPLY
REQUIRE A GENDER ANALYSIS
ASSESSMENT OF THE PROGRAM.
BY SIGNALING THE IMPORTANCE OF
INCLUDING MORE GENDER DIVERSITY
THE PROGRAM.
IT'S NOT JUST IMPORTANT, IT IS
SMART.
>> Laura: HOW WORRIED DO YOU
THINK CHINA AND RUSSIA ARE ABOUT
THEIR LACK OF A GENDER ANALYSIS
IN THEIR MILITARY TRAINING?
IT'S EMBARRASSING.
WE SEE THIS CHANGE IN OUR
MILITARY IDENTITY, DON'T WE.
THE TYPE OF RECRUITMENT VIDEOS
THEY ARE PRODUCING THESE DAYS.
DURING REAGAN AND THE '80s,
THE VIDEOS LOOKED LIKE THIS.
>> ♪♪ REACHING DEEP INSIDE YOU ♪
♪ THINGS YOU'VE NEVER KNOWN ♪
♪ IT'S BEEN TOUGH, ROUGH GOING ♪
♪ BUT YOU HAVEN'T BEEN ALONE ♪♪
>> WE DO MORE BEFORE 9:00 A.M.
THAN MOST PEOPLE DO ALL DAY.
>> ♪♪ BE ALL THAT YOU CAN BE ♪
♪ FIND YOUR FUTURE IN THE
ARMY ♪♪
>> Laura: DON'T YOU WANT TO GO
BACK TO THE '80s?
PATRIOTIC, TOTALLY COOL.
THIS IS HOW THEY RECRUIT TODAY.
>> THIS IS THE STORY OF A
SOLDIER WHO OPERATES THE PATRIOT
MISSILE DEFENSE SYSTEM.
IT BEGINS IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH A LITTLE GIRL RAISED BY TWO
MOMS.
>> Laura: LITERALLY.
THEY ARE USING CARTOONS.
WHY IS HAVING TWO MOMMIES
RELEVANT AT ALL?
THE ANSWER IS IT'S NOT.
THAT WOULD GET A A IS A WOMAN
STUDIES PROJECT BUT IT FAILED IN
RECRUITING SOLDIERS DEPARTMENT.
THE FACT IS OUR MILITARY
LEADERSHIP HAS JUST ROLLED OVER
FOR THE MOST RADICAL LEFT WING
IDEAS OUT THERE.
IN OUR MILITARY, INCLUDING INNER
MILITARY ACADEMIES THEY ARE
ACTIVELY TEACHING CRT AND
ACTIVELY PROMOTING THE TRANS AND
SEXUAL IDENTITY AGENDA.
AFTER SPEAKING WITH SEVERAL
MILITARY SOURCES FROM ENLISTED
MEN TO RECENT GRADS, THE ANGLE
BELIEVES THIS RECRUITMENT CRISIS
IS A SELF-INFLICTED WOUND BY THE
WOKE STIRS.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER IF THIS IS
THEIR GOAL.
JUST AS IT'S THEIR GOALS AND
FORCE YOU TO SUFFER ECONOMIC
PAIN FOR THEIR TRANSITIONS TO
CLEAN ENERGY.
ISN'T THAT A GOAL TO DESTROY OUR
ALL VOLUNTEER FORCE IN ORDER TO
PAVE THE WAY FOR A SMALLER
GLOBAL FORCE?
IT'S 2022.
WE FACE AN AGGRESSIVE ADVERSARY
IN COMMUNIST CHINA.
OUR STANDING ARMY IS CONTRACTING
AS THEIRS IS GROWING.
IN FACT, IT'S FAR LARGER THAN
OURS IS NOW.
FROM PUTIN'S MERCILESS RAMPAGE
ACROSS UKRAINE TO CHINA'S
MENACING ACTIONS NEAR TAIWAN, WE
ALREADY SEE THE BALANCE OF POWER
BEGINNING TO TIP AWAY FROM THE
U.S.
HUNTER BIDEN IN THE WOKE
MILITARY LEADERSHIP, OUR ENEMIES
ARE GETTING BOLDER AND BOLDER BY
THE DAY.
THE ENTIRE TIME TRUMP WAS IN
OFFICE, THE MILITARY KEPT
PUTTING UP ROADBLOCKS TO THE
CHANGES THAT HE WANTED TO MAKE
INCLUDING THEIR WITHDRAWAL FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
THE PENTAGON AND ALL ITS
ARROGANCE, RESISTED
PRESIDENT TRUMP EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY.
THIS IS HOW MUCH POWER THEY
HAVE.
THEY ARE ALMOST A GOVERNMENT
UNTO THEIR OWN.
G.O.P. MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WHO
HAVE A MORAL OBLIGATION RIGHT
NOW TO HOLD HEARINGS, CARRY OUT
INVESTIGATIONS, AND DEMAND REAL
REFORM.
WE LOVE OUR ENLISTED TROOPS AND
WE CHERISH THEIR HEROIC
SACRIFICES.
THEY DON'T DESERVE THIS.
CONGRESS SHOULD NOT JUST KEEP
SHOVELING MONEY OUT THE DOOR
REGARDLESS OF THE RESULTS BUT
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
BIDEN ASKED FOR $802 BILLION FOR
THE NEXT YEAR DEFENSE BUDGET.
THE HOUSE ENDED UP VOTING TO
ROUNDED UP TO A COOL
$839 BILLION.
UNREAL.
AMERICA IS QUICKLY MOVING FROM A
POSITION WHEN WE ASK WHAT SHOULD
WE DO IN INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS
TO ONE WHERE WE ASK, CAN WE DO
ANYTHING?
WHEN THE AMERICAN TAXPAYERS HAVE
SPENT TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
OUR MILITARY AND LOST THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF BRAVE AND
SELFLESS TROOPS, WE HAVE A RIGHT
AND WE HAVE A DUTY TO REQUIRE
ACCOUNTABILITY ACROSS THE BOARD.
IT'S BAD ENOUGH THAT AMERICANS
HAVE LOST FAITH IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
SECTOR AND OUR GOVERNMENT IN
GENERAL BUT IT'S AMERICANS -- IF
AMERICANS LOSE FAITH IN OUR